oh god oh god
i'm so scared what's that corpse yeah
is this something
hey felix
do you know where i am
[Music]
welcome to a manga we're gonna switch it
up a little bit this time yeah hide and
seek is something we want to try out
yeah yeah yeah you guys have seen that
already i understand
yeah
you have to give us a head start
we gotta go hide wait what are the rules
are we allowed to speak i'm so confused
yeah yeah this time we speak
i've got to find you guys and kill you i
can't see as far as you can do we have
to stay in the one spot no you can move
okay nice
oh
all right guys it's dave
i'm pretty sure it's dave so now you've
done that we're all going to reset so
yeah we're going to go hard again all
right i'm giving you until my cool kill
cool down goes off and then i'm looking
okay get my hot spot nerd what are you
doing how many seconds are you on dave
i'm i'm right i'm looking
oh god he's looking he's coming to get
away from my spot
oh i'm perfectly hidden right can i just
use the vents to look around for it
instead is that no no no no no no no no
use those invidi legs of yours i guess
i'm just going to judge it by the sounds
you guys make because i can't really see
very much
i am not over there
you guys give me any clues uh finding
nothing at the moment oh that's crazy
come on you're a serial killer syracuse
don't ask oh i don't know i don't think
he's ever gonna find his pda we're too
good oh no you know you've been trying
well i want to make it easy on you come
on it won't be too hard
i appreciate it
just good science i'll give a hint i'm
next to pj
peter where the [ __ ] did he go
i don't know if you know this map well
enough to know what would be satisfying
on it what's satisfying to you
okay perfect leave me alone get lost
science you're in specifying spot
[Music]
am i
no you're not
this is really hard
is everyone's just running away from me
and you're not staying at home i i
haven't got a lot we're playing hide and
seek we're not supposed to do the test
does it hurt you that much
you know
felix's check we'll [ __ ] yourselves
thank you he's out there playing the
game like
that's why i don't play with anybody
we created a monster now dude all right
dave dave you're cold again
what
hulk
[Laughter]
i guess you were less than uh pda right
yeah i was the last alive i guess that
means you won and said he's down to join
as well
after this
um it fellers
okay yeah all right we're doing
testimony
wait hold on i just realized how
how is this different from a regular
game of among us
cause we know the ambassador no yeah
yeah i'm such a [ __ ] idiot
uh who is the imposter side in here i
can alright it is me no i'm scared every
single person i run by right it's so
scary going into specimen because you're
just trapped
i mean i'm not going in space
[Laughter]
i don't have any button left what am i
supposed to do oh no
pj are you alive yes i'm alive
i like this this is a nice change i
don't have to lie to anyone
i don't have to sit in the lobby
you don't die immediately and then get
bored with me
if we split up from the woman if we
split
in cells now daddy please i just started
[Music]
if i wasn't so blind you'd all be dead
yeah oh god
yeah that's the point james
that was scary yeah every person i come
across now is potential death
pastor faster professor why are my tiny
little boy hands not working
where is everyone don't know
do not
[Laughter]
i'm like oh
right
especially the long ones so we still
gotta do it as good as our test is good
yeah
oh so tempting to click report but i'm
not gonna do it
[Laughter]
again healthy
yep i'm thinking oh please don't please
don't please don't please don't
god we're not even halfway to task yeah
where'd you go
we got this
jukes the jukes
hey what's up jesus i was looking at
discord
are you imposter
it's not me i swear
guys i found a body hey cover me jack
cover me oh god cover me uh scream
scream if you see something oh my god
come with me
[ __ ] worst all right all my tasks are
done uh i think god i have one left wait
no where are you guys yeah i'm done i'm
done okay all right this is a good strat
sticking together let me i already left
bro
you're sick
i gotta do my task
safety and numbers my tasks are done
i got two left
it's all up to me
the swing
one more felix what are you doing the
last task
in comes oh my god oh my god
and what no not comms why did you just
say that why did you say that it's fine
[Applause]
[Music]
that was so close oh my god
jesus that's really fun hey what's up
cops hey you made it howdy
we're playing hide and seek playing on
the beta or unlike the regular version
uh
i'm on beta branch i don't think whoever
set up the servers on that so i don't
think it matters oh
you can turn off the taskbar until
you're in meetings all right do we have
safe here as well so if you want to jump
in
yeah hey
what's going on
we've been playing it wrong this whole
time yeah
okay whatever's impossible who is it
it's me okay oh no
easy give us like 10 seconds to get out
of here yeah
nine uh
yeah don't report anything corpses
[Laughter]
okay
my murders saved you yeah thank you for
that all right keep doing that thing
that you're doing oh then okay okay i'm
done i'm done then let's go
oh my god
uh who's in there who's there
[Laughter]
okay
some genuine fear in your voice left
it's me
oh there you are
okay
[Laughter]
i don't even know who it is
good job boys good job boys dead body
i'm rooting you from beyond the grave
kevin we're not seeing you no
[Music]
this is so hard it's because of the the
distance the view distance
for once it's fun not being impostor
oh my god
we got the strike corpse
okay my tasks are done
oh my god just went straight past me so
scary yeah that room is a death trap
okay okay
oh
i'm not saying
i gotta do it instantly i've literally
done like 10 laps around the map and i
just can't see anyone
where are you guys hiding like what the
[ __ ] that's the stretch oh
okay
nice yeah
good brush
ken don't go there don't go there
okay okay okay okay
wait wait wait wait where i oh
corpse you're a lucky man oh my god i
have to go i have one more which one do
you have okay
keep going okay
[Laughter]
oh my god i have to go so far oh god
oh so dumb
you're close
close oh
okay okay this way this way this way i
have one more who's got that last ass i
think it's me and that's one oh god it's
a two-parter
okay it must be reacted then or
something jesus this is way harder on
imposter than i thought it would be okay
we got it we got it we got it buddy oh
you were so close one more what the [ __ ]
oh no
it never ends
now right yeah boy
yeah
we weren't even hiding we were just
doing tests
uh put a discord overlay if anyone
wanted a jacket i want that oh yeah you
got to put
50 hours into the game first that would
be the only good reason to play this
game 150 hours
oh god all right who is it
do we do we oh it's me it's me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
just kill us as quickly as you can
oh okay sorry ken
comes oh we're not doing a countdown
this time okay
[Laughter]
you gotta okay i won't kill you he saw
him are you safe
he was too slow replying you'll never
find me here i got the best spot
you could have warned me about that
yeah
maybe not holy crap
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh hold on hold on jaden you probably
weren't right side to do your no did you
no i didn't
oh god dice
oh
me and you again uh i'm i'm keeping dave
to last oh you're keeping what
oh
this is like an actual horror movie yeah
what the [ __ ]
jaden do you know i'll allow you to do
your noise
[Applause]
all right
[Laughter]
dave has been a snake somewhere for sure
we were supposed to split oh god how are
you dude
send me to dave uh dave where are you
dave he's somewhere he's holding me on
stage
he's okay i've got him
come to the drop ship i'll bring your
friend
pewdiepie i'm doing good
we're gonna do a transfer here kill me
please
also you he has two children as well
it's three lives for one here good for
the kids man dropped yeah
[Laughter]
okay admin table is unfair don't use
admin table after after me oh i see
wow no one else is here what a tryhard
jesus
and you're a st oh yeah you're a cat
girl man respect hell yeah respect
respect
bro oh yeah respect the cacophony after
i watched
atari i'm like i'm in
i get it now everybody should watch
anime at least once
for the experience
there's a new one there's a new one
that's really good jiu-jitsu casein
that's a new animated camera cause
actually i'll watch anime here that's
sick pandemic bro what else are we gonna
do
i do games in 2d titties
[Laughter]
shame whenever i'm watching anime my
wife will walk in it'll be at that one
part you know that fan service part
she's like oh yeah what are you watching
are you watching food wars food wars
especially yeah what the [ __ ]
i'm i'm sticking to cat ears for a while
oh my god
with cat ears
a corpse is going to ruin his own life
now oh i i've already done that
finally
i don't i don't need the caterers to
ruin my life
[Music]
my name made it into one of your songs
oh yeah it makes me very happy oh is it
is it technically your name or felix's
name
it's mine jesus said it about me
the whole [ __ ] year of felix meaming
me
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] i kind of want to try this
i feel like don't even know because you
can get the tasks quicker all right all
right everyone everyone line up everyone
line up okay and we'll do a race it's
over the greenhouse is gone
all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
how many lives
my brain just works different i thought
you guys went down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh god
wait
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
ruby was walking really slow i can
safely assume he's not on board everyone
okay i don't know where your tasks are
or you don't know when you're done oh
it's me i'm imposter
[Music]
you're blocking
do you want to flee for your life or
something
[Laughter]
let me finish this task first oh you
didn't see me uh i saw you i just let
you live like you said yes of course
yeah
i'm the other
pewdiepie oh that was close that was
close what color is felix wait what i'm
uh nothing
[Laughter]
don't go that way
wait what happened
i saw your little pig head really
yes through the door you're in decom no
and that two people ran to electric
oh god not saying that because i'm
nowhere near electric
oh
oh my god
no
no no no
you guys want to fix lights nope
i'm fixing it as we speak pewds
oh look i'm clicking it now of course i
think that's the best lighting i've ever
heard you do
all right i'm not the imposter i i fixed
the lights don't worry guys oh thank you
thank you so don't hold me up all right
okay my tasks are done
my test's almost done yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you're going to lose
you have to kill five people
okay
all right all my class done i've got one
task left
you got this thing we got this i'm
hiding in a very heidi spot
where you gotta go
[Music]
i wanted to get pj and then i ditched
course and i would regret everything
come back corpse please
come back corpse i'm sorry
you're very
cheater i wouldn't give me that kick
what the [ __ ] are these made up roles
out of nowhere pj
i fed you to the line i'm sorry
all right still got 10 seconds before we
can win uh plenty of time
that taskbar is looking pretty full
damn it oh yeah
oh i split up work
never imposter i don't get anything god
why am i why am i three times impossible
with you oh no protect me
got 10 seconds
i'm giving a countdown everything i know
right why i just oh god i don't know
where my tasks are oh crap for my
channel
guys guys don't go to comps don't go to
columns okay
go to pumps
where's my task
if something glows it means it's your
task i didn't know that
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh they're just in an argument they're
figuring it out
no
[Music]
this is smooth freeze we're fine we're
fine easy showers
how did you see them our last task is oh
yes
god damn there's a lot of dead bodies
there i don't think i'm not there side
left left left yes this will work go
left left down down down left left left
left side
out
straight straight straight straight
straight no no no stop you're going the
wrong way
[Laughter]
all right guys he's chasing me just so
you know he's chasing me i saw that oh
keep running keep letting him chase you
yay
[Applause]
i think he's watched too many memes
[Music]
all right you don't have to lie now at
least joel you can't win an imposter for
once it's called don't worry buddy yeah
yeah yeah
i didn't memorize it
what color are you what color are you
doing white blue green
green green green near
okay
wait a minute
[Laughter]
other players where uh uh killer is
maybe not if you're a ghost yeah okay
yeah okay
like oh be careful
i'll just judge by how loud you all get
right
i'm hiding thank you players guys
not close guys okay that's okay that's
good
cloudy skies cloudy skies
guys very sorry stormfront hot pressure
coming in
oh god it's i forgot it's not safe
jack it's a very mighty waters
okay
i'm i'm taking it
so the others can finish their tasks
[Music]
maybe we shouldn't say who the imposter
ends next time let's try that next
that's terrifying
yeah
i like it
all right coming who do you trust
no no no
they've covered me to cover me
yeah
thank you you're gonna kill me okay i'll
i'll cover your tell me
i actually i actually outrun the killer
wait i don't have to go here
i don't know what i have to do
don't go that way uh no it's fine i know
how to play v-day
behind you
that's what i said
oh my god oh my god that was so tense
let's go i'm done okay i'm lonely oh
well done
me and ruby you're being rude for
i guess you can yell it out but like the
first kill i guess you wouldn't know who
it is yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe whoever
gets killed can say it it just gets
progressively more quiet
uh it's not me it's not me is it not me
not me not me
not me is it corbs
oh my god it's course what a man
it's not sean
of course please please don't do it
please don't do it please please please
please
kill her please
oh god did he give you the kiss to death
[Laughter]
this is way scarier
all right
[Music]
what did corpse do to you where'd he
touch you
pointing at the doll where he touched
you
i just saw one short scream there
like the shortest little
screech
oh
[Applause]
was about to live the rest of his life
in fear just from those 10 seconds
square room
oh
corpse corpse corpse course not that way
not that way he did not worry don't go
in there you don't go tonight
side of the map you haven't been on
corpse oh unfortunately
don't do it
smaller dude don't do it jade um don't
do it
i'll do the spooky halloween [ __ ] jayden
oh nice
i'm getting so close to slime that was
cold don't worry i don't know if it's i
don't know if it's cheap
it is tayden it's jake it's got to be or
it's pewdiepie one of the others i'm
dead
so much slime
world's going as a group right oh god
[Laughter]
so did we confirm that it was or was not
here right i'm not going to speak
anymore
we need more data
no we don't the data is that my head is
not on my body anymore
i can't say who did it that guy or would
you trust someone who's alive that's a
good point actually yeah that is it
could be me even i trust her no she's an
admiral you're on the camps i'll i'll
i'll cover you joe run job
[Music]
nice one okay we got it like a few
did you do your tasks oh jen's coming
yes i'm done i'm done i'm done jen's
going oh she sure is come on dave
i'll protect you i protect you
thank you
all right you're good maybe i'll stand
in a really common hallway you're good
oh you're not good run
rise not good
these these chances feel so slow yeah
yeah
okay you're good you're getting it it's
the slowest serial killer of all time
okay
that is true
so wait what update me on this again we
are allowed to do the emergency meeting
if you're getting changed but only if
you're getting chased yeah an
did we change anything else
i'm imposter okay
okay which color are you changing
i'm orange i'm orange no you're probably
not i'm orange
i see your name over
god it's so scary going corydoras
of course don't you test this time
everybody
thank you guys oh oh is that he actually
is this oh god oh you killed me from the
other side of the table
[Laughter]
your bullets
yeah i'm in reactor at the minute so
please stay away you're [ __ ] lying
he's lying he's next to me he's lying
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh guys i think my game is bugged i
couldn't vote
you're dead
hey jaden i won't kill you if you leave
me to your teammates cause you got
better vision you promise is that yeah
that's the deal that's a deal
i don't know what i have oh yeah i
remember now yeah
where's your teammates jayden take one
for the team take them on the tv
[Music]
it wouldn't be ethically
no you don't have to
okay mr ethics
unmorally
where is everyone right if the meeting
is called the killer has told me that
because this is the intention yeah maybe
oh no no no all right he's a cafeteria
he's in cup terror i have one task left
where is he
where the [ __ ] are you guys
i can't see them yeah now it's the last
test
wow swap things around a little bit here
crew my vision really low and pass the
vision really high
but they're kill cooldowns 25 seconds
no longer that's too short yeah longer
longer
yeah yeah longer like 90 seconds 30 30.
35 30 30 30 30 20 32 and a half take a
release 40 they take my
lies okay it's all right 40 it is
holy infinite cooldown
i feel bad impossible i couldn't walk
around for 40 seconds okay i'm not
nothing
uh who is it spoopy what's your what's
your guys favorite
scary movie
casper
the new adam sandler one
i can't believe i can watch movies for a
while oh god great movie yeah really
good okay i'm jesus christ
did someone just die
no no no
oh is it joel is it actually usual
did you die jack oh you're like
but death came for me very quickly
then who is it
we gotta work together here you should
have listened to me
i don't hear any smooches it can't be
corpses oh god no i definitely don't see
anything oh my god all i can see is like
holy [ __ ]
i just see my feet
what's saying possibly
they can see everything right yeah okay
i've done all my tests
ah would you look at that it's pewds uh
yeah it's me
oh who is that who's blue jayden
jaden
who is it
i'm so scared i was just kidding
it's a good place to hide
don't worry boys come on tactical
bailout in common
[Laughter]
oh i thought that was the last task well
there's one tackle the last one i got
that i thought oh my gosh go inside
please
chadian
[Music]
i literally killed almost immediately
i'll never cool down but nothing like
that you're like 30. all right all right
maybe i said 40 and maybe a bad idea
maybe
[Laughter]
everybody i need a little bit of an
imposter inside
i don't don't think
i don't think i think jaden is clear i
think so too
i know who it is uh
who is it cyber are you clear apostrophe
simon
jennings pj maybe i don't know
come watch
[Laughter]
i did see spedicy just run away from me
what the [ __ ] was that spicy
not listen
what's that corpse
[Music]
yeah is this something there
hey felix
do you know where i am
[Laughter]
do you know who
where i am
if he's on cooldown now's a good time to
do a long task everybody yeah
yeah yeah
long task really short
[Music]
yeah
all right he is a cool down if we do our
tasks very quick okay we could
we have a minute 30 seconds to finish
every task okay
oh god damn it this guy's so intense
no
now i can do it faster
yeah jokes on you jack
one second a mile upload left oh my god
dude that was so close maybe it's slower
the slowest
yes
so tense
i'm trying to run but i
can't these legs
don't work
why now legs the killer teleports
uh all right who is it please
i can't fail
i can't deal with this [ __ ] please i
just saw the kill i just saw the killer
kill yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i i can't
am i i'm not allowed to tell you
well if you're not dead you can tell us
oh it's sean
no it's not but he said it's sean he's
not doing this poopy voice it's my name
is jack
guys
uh no no it's definitely him it's
definitely him it can't be in he's in a
container or something
imposters always echo where is he where
is he where is he
[Laughter]
someone need an emergency button i'm
doing it for joel no he's safe all right
who is it he's not technical or not he's
safe
now i saw sean kill someone but i think
it's joe
i agree
[Laughter]
are you guys going huh i know where my
attach guard is don't do nothing i'm
going
okay
[Laughter]
oh
don't fix it you'll never go left go
let's go
[Laughter]
i can't believe it's me
i gotta head out thanks for playing guys
good man
hope you guys enjoyed as well thanks for
watching the stream will be available
for members make sure you sign up for
member it all goes to charity yeah
live your life have fun see you tomorrow
[Music]